hi everyone this is Jana Madhvi kamar
bringing you some highlights from the
world rapid championships it was a
pretty disastrous first day for Magnus
who managed to lose his first two games
against opponents he really should
manage to beat however he did turn it
around with three wins to end the day
and this was one of them with the white
pieces against Grandmaster Vlasov and
and Magnus timed an exchange sacrifice
perfectly in this position black has a
reasonably solid setup but Magnus
crashed through giving up his rook for a
knight and upon so by doing this he
opened up the position but the point was
tactical because he had seen this move
c5 opening up for the bishop pointing
towards the rook and that forces the
rook to go back after which Magnus
established a passed pawn on c6 and and
this pawn is so strong there's basically
nothing black can do about it and in
desperation will also have decided the
only way to stop this from queening is
to play rook c8 and after Knight b5
simply taking it out that is how strong
that pawn was it drove black to very
desperate measures but after takes back
takes first of all white has two pieces
for a rope so he's already pretty happy
with this trade but also Magnus playing
rook a7 over the course of the next
couple of moves he was able to capture
this pawn on f5 he got the pawn on f5 he
even got the pawn on d6 a couple of
moves
later and the whole black position
collapsed